[Music]
do not be fooled by our
politeness our bows are am of
rituals death is in our
air and sea and
Earth just
remember we live and we
die we control nothing Beyond
that there's a saying out here every man
has three
hearts one in his mouth for the world to
know another in his chest just for his
friends and the secret
heart buried
[Music]
deep where no one can find it
what kind of man wields power in a land
like
Vision the one with the open or the one
you never
see when I die here
likly war is coming
life and death are the
same both can have value and
purpose this is not where we die we
should be corpses I now but here we
are my life is mine and yours is
yours if you can't see that he'll never
be free of this
prison it is you who always imprisoned
freedom is all you ever live
[Music]
[Applause]
for
death is in our
air and sea and
Earth it can come for us at any
[Music]
moment
yes
[Music]